[Music]
once
once once upon a time there was
something oh I'm not sure if I can
remember this how it goes once upon a
time it was something really was quite
beautiful it was delightful yeah just
imagine something delightful once upon a
time there was something delightful okay
I'm okay with this
I hope you're okay with this
you know I don't know why they gave me
my own show because I'm a mess really
the world is getting to me lately I
really thought by this point the human
beings would be doing better so I'm
going through a grim period plans
plans plans with tar tar sauce
the phone rings and it's flea John I
can't even share my own self up John hey
so I'm gonna have him on the show John
uh how are you doing
I'm gonna lie down
this show
it's a variety show
but all these complicated plots are
introduced they found us they're coming
that looks good yeah very good
ah that is really something
I promise you the stories I tell on here
they're all true except for the stories
of course that are obviously not true
right that is right John
I mean the odds were against me I
survived some stuff in this life and I'm
proud that I'm still here
and I put beautiful things into this
world
and I hope to keep doing that
I was like okay and then I came back a
little bit on the humans
I'll give them another chance
[Music]